today's DOJ announcement that it was
dropping Mike Flynn's prosecution is
fantastic news it's long overdue but
what is general fling go to get the past
three years back or the millions of
dollars he lost defending himself or the
pain and suffering it caused him and his
family
now as happy as I am for Flynn and I'm
very happy I am utterly disgusted that
this could have ever happened to a
decorated war vet to any American who
just wanted to serve his government one
more time as national security advisor
but what they did to Flynn is what you
get for working for a government that
the Democrats don't like what they did
to Flynn is merely part of a sick 4-year
continuum where Democrats and their
never Trump allies have abused their
power in an effort to prevent the normal
functioning of our government that would
have benefited all of us by the way now
they saw his victory Trump's victory in
2016 as a sin for which Trump and his
supporters must be punished and their
credo is rule or ruin we will either
rule the country or will ruin it an old
boy have they worked overtime to
accomplish the latter now tonight we're
naming names members of an abuse of
power Hall of Shame these stories can't
be read and it can't be understood
really in isolation for they were all
evidence of a deeply undemocratic strain
that has become a cancer on the Democrat
Party metastasizing throughout the
entire body politic before the FBI's
effort to entrap Flynn the Obama Intel
Chiefs Brennan clapper and the Obama DOJ
and FBI put in motion the Russian
collusion investigation they abuse their
power against low-level aides like
George papadopolis they abuse their
power in filing FISA applications to
surveil Carter page and they abuse their
power in relying on a Russian dossier
funded by the Clinton campaign even when
they could
verify its claims FBI director call me
abused his power in the entire Flynn
saga as well so did acting Attorney
General Sally Yates who allowed an
interview with the president's new NSA
chief to go forward and of course there
was the crooked FBI agent Peter struck
and his insurance policy that he
mentioned to his lovebird Lisa page they
went after Flynn on a pretext they
already knew that he'd spoken with the
Russian ambassador because they had the
call transcript but they set up this
interview in hopes that he would step
into a perjury trap when former FBI head
of intelligent when t17 Flynn meeting
were revealed last week they showed just
that this was the only justice that
could have been handed down